COLT MCANLIS: Hey, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And I'm a developer advocate at
Google focusing on Native
Client and gaming.
And what we're going to
talk about today is
getting your port on.
Specifically, porting your
game to Native Client
as of Pepper 18.
So a quick show of hands,
who's already
touched Native Client?
Have you compiled the
application before?
OK.
Cool.
Put your hands down.
For those you, how many people
have no idea what
Native Client is?
Or they've heard about it and
want to learn more, and that's
why you're here?
OK.
Cool.
That's good.
That allows me to kind
of gauge how
deep I dive into stuff.
So Pepper 18 is the active SDK
build, as of right now.
If you go to gonacl.com, you'll
be able to get our SDK
and see all the documentation
that we're talking about
today, as well as some other
amazing opportunities there.
So let's get started.
So it works.
Native Client allows
you to run C and C
code in a web page.
Now this has been around
as a feature set
for a long time now.
But the most important thing,
and probably the coolest one
about Native Client, is that
no plug-in is required.
Now this is the kicker, right?
I've got some statistical
information sitting in a vault
somewhere that shows that, for
some games, they lose up to
90% of the users that wanted
to play the game as soon as
they are prompted to
install a plug-in.
90%.
Now if you're an indie in this
crowd, and you've got a
mortgage and a wife and a
mother-in-law who thinks
you're a bum because you're
a game developer and not a
stockbroker, or something, 90%
of those developers wanted to
give you money.
And they couldn't because
you asked them
to install a plug-in.
So the goal here is
if no plug-in is
required, that's fantastic.
And if you're one of the
programmers who has worked in
the games industry for the past
30 years, chances are
you've got 30 years of C code
sitting around and 30 years of
experience in C code sitting
around that can now migrate to
the web, which is
amazing, right?
Developers spend billions of
dollars cultivating this
technology.
And to get to the web right
now, they have to throw it
away and rewrite it in some
other scripting language.
But if you can use the direct
code, this is fantastic.
It allows you to leverage your
existing technology to move
into this new marketplace.
So here's the gist. It all
starts with your C code.
Native Client provides, in the
SDK, a version of a GCC and a
G compiler that produces safe,
portable x86 code.
This is provided in the
form of NEXEs, or
Native Client exe.
In addition to this, we'll
produce one for 32-bit and
64-bit architectures, as well
as an NMF file, or a Native
Client manifest file.
The manifest effectively lists
which architecture goes to
what file path for
what executable.
So it says if you're running
a 32-bit, point to this
executable.
If you're running 64-bit,
run to that executable.
You embed this information in an
HTML file using this small,
little tag right here.
So you make an embed element.
You name it.
You give it a height.
You define your manifest.
You point to the
manifest, not to the NEXEs.
Because, remember, the
manifest defines
what NEXE to use.
And then you set an application
type right there.
Once you do this, you've gone
through this process.
You've compiled it.
You've embedded it in a page.
And then you load the
page up and boom!
You see some amazing graphics on
the screen, stuff that you
traditionally don't
see in a web game.
This is actually a screen shot
from an Xbox 360 title running
in Native Client that was ported
in about three months.
That's amazing technology to see
post processing and full
screen blend and skin animation
and color tint and
all this just great stuff
there that you
have access to now.
So let's talk about the
first steps, your
GCC and your G compiler.
So to use these-- if anyone
here is a Linux developer,
then you're very intimately
familiar with GCC and G If
you're a Windows developer,
this is kind of new ground
that's kind of awkward and
uncomfortable for you.
But first off, to get your code
compiling in GCC and G ,
you have to make sure that it's
ISO and IEC complaint,
which effectively means that it
matches these protocols and
these standards.
Now it's probably not best to go
look at these standards and
figure out the mapping.
It's probably actually best to
try to compile your code in
GCC, figure out what it
complains about, and then
iterate that way.
Predominately, this standard
defines POSIX style coding and
functioning.
So it uses syntaxes like p
threads as opposed to begin
and end thread, as well as
conditional variables rather
than retexes and other
things like that.
In addition, this compliance
standard-- and this is the
important one--
does not define any
OS specific calls.
So you can't access the
registry from GCC.
That doesn't make sense.
You can't open up a direct
video stream
using direct media.
That doesn't make sense
either, right?
So you need to make sure that
your code is platform
independent and uses these
POSIX-style calls.
The GCC and G compilers also
do the amazing thing-- and
this is sort of the linchpin--
it removes any unsafe code.
This is the whole point
of Native Client.
The whole point is to execute
safe, portable assembly
language code in
a web browser.
Security is of the utmost
importance here, more than
performance, more than
anything else.
Although we are amazingly
performant.
And I can give you those numbers
offline, if you're
looking for it.
But it removes all this unsafe
stuff and creates this nice
little package that can run,
execute, in multiple places.
And so once you get this code--
and you're saying, OK,
this is cool.
I have the ability to
execute this code--
how does it actually interact
with the system?
So to understand how Native
Client gets access to these
system-level resources, I have
to take a step back, and
actually talk about how Chrome,
the web browser, gets
access to these system-level
resources.
So a long time ago, a company
made a plug-in architecture
called NPAPI.
Effectively, this plug-in
architecture allowed plug-ins
to be developed for a browser
that then had access to lower
level systems in various
ways, so that users
can install the plug-in.
And if the plug-in dll targeted
these header files,
it had access to these things.
Well, the problem was that
at its heyday, this NPAPI
architecture was actually the
number one problem of malware
and bugs in the environment.
So Chrome went ahead and said,
we're going to support NPAPI.
But we want to create a safer
version, so that we don't have
to worry about all these
pop-ups, and
spyware, and malware.
So we created what we call the
Pepper API, or PPAPI, which is
a plug-in architecture that
allows you to target file IO,
rendering, audio, and even
have the ability to
communicate back to the page
that's hosting the plug-in
through JavaScript post
message results.
So understanding this, that
there's effectively a Pepper
API that allows plug-ins to
access these inner workings
through Chrome, Native Client
is effectively a module that
communicates with this.
So your NEXE file, when you
compile it, you'll target
these specific headers to do
things like file IO, audio,
rendering, and JavaScript.
This is how your program gets
access to the lower level
architecture.
Now it's worth noting this, too,
is that the Pepper thread
is actually running on the
main thread of Chrome.
So your Native Client module is
sitting there doing execution.
Also on this main thread,
though, are some other
important buddies that you
need to be aware of.
First off is WebKit.
WebKit executes on
the same thread.
This is the layout
organizational DOM rendering
style engine.
It is out there open source.
Also V8, which is Chrome's
virtual machine for handling
JavaScript, as well as some
other fun stuff like Web RTC,
audio processing, video, and
all this other stuff.
The important takeaway you
should see here is that your
Native Client module has the
ability to effectively stall
out this main thread not
doing correctly.
So if you go in and put a spin
loop on your main thread,
you're effectively going to
halt the entire web page,
because the WebKit doesn't get
the input processing, and V8
doesn't get JavaScript
processing.
So it's going to stall the tab
and effectively crash out.
Because of this, you're not
supposed to call any blocking
functions on the main thread.
This is a bad idea, so none of
your code should be calling
blocking functions on
the main thread.
And because of that, the
Pepper API's are all
asynchronous.
None of them are blocking
at all.
This means that you can call the
Pepper API from the main
thread, and then some
time in the future
you'll get that result.
Generally, that's
about one frame.
So if you looked at that
previous diagram, you can see
that we've got WebKit, we've
got V8, and then we've got
NaCl and some other stuff.
So if NaCl says, hey, I want
to go load this file, it's
going to kick off a request. And
then we have to generally
wait until WebKit, V8 gets
processed and the plug-in
frame gets processed before
those results can be given
back to the main thread of your
Native Client module.
Also, one of the restrictions
of Pepper is that all the
Pepper API's must be called
from the main
thread right now.
This is a current restriction
that our team is actively
working on to fix.
But this has some potential
downsides that you
need to be aware of.
Before we dive into
that, let's talk
about how this works.
So on the top here we've got a
function that shows how to do
file layout.
So we've got a function.
We're asserting that this is
coming from the main thread.
We get some information
from the user.
And we actually call
FileIO.Open.
With FileIO.Open you actually
provide a completion callback.
The completion callback will
occur once this file open
request has occurred at the
lower level, the Pepper API
level, and the results of that
will be pushed back to you.
That's the second function
here you can see
open, f open callback.
This will get called on your
main thread once everything
has been done in the lower
bowels of Chrome and the
Pepper API's.
And then you can, yay,
do some stuff.
Show a cat.
Issue a read.
Whatever you need to
do at that point.
So this is sort of a problem.
Because this works in a very
different way than all of your
architectures.
This is not how your game
engine is designed.
I can guarantee this
is not how your
game engine is designed.
Even if you have asynchronous
loading in your game, sooner
or later you're going
to expect f read
as a blocking function.
You've got everything
working around that.
More importantly, you probably
have f read calls coming from
the main thread, which, in
general, is a problem.
So the point next is how do
you design around this?
How do you beat this?
How do you say--
how do I touch my code?
Well, one idea is to modify
all of your f reads to use
this blocking callback system.
Or how do you do these
other things?
Make sure the thread
doesn't stall.
Forget all that.
I'm going to give you the
shortcut I'm going to drop
some wisdom on you.
I'm going to point my knowledge
cannon in your
direction, and give you
a blast of info.
The best idea is to actually
spin up a thread and run your
main game logic on
that thread.
And leave the original main
thread as the Pepper thread.
Basically, what this allows you
to do is you wrap all of
your platform functions to issue
communication back and
forth to the main thread.
Let's take a look at what
that looks like here.
So your game has the Pepper
thread or the main thread.
That spawns off your
logic thread.
Now the logic thread is
effectively going to run the
main loop, while true--
update, render, network, update,
network, render.
Do all that stuff.
And it's going to just continue
doing that on the
logic thread.
The Pepper thread is the
only access to FileIO,
JavaScript, and audio.
Your logic thread should not
have direct access to that.
Instead, the logic thread will
call specific commands, which
pushes a function to the
Pepper thread and
then it will block.
The Pepper thread will then
receive that function,
communicate off to the lower
level IO, do its fun stuff,
return that data to the Pepper
thread, and the Pepper thread
will then return that
data to your logic
thread in the fashion.
What this means is that you can
overload f read, f write,
blocking functions like that,
to effectively do the same
thing that you would
expect them to
already do in your game.
You just effectively create this
abstraction layer around
them, so that it actually
communicates with the Pepper
thread in a proper manner
without actually having to
touch all the lines
of code that
you've already got written.
Here's an example of how
to look at this.
So this top function here
is request and wait.
So what this will do is assert
that, first off, you're not
running on the main thread.
You're running on
a worker thread.
And Native Client and Pepper
actually provide a nice little
API that will auto call your
function on the main thread on
your behalf, so that you don't
have to write all the
intricate threading, and
messaging, and queuing logic
to get it to call there.
So simply, you call
module.get.core.
Call on main thread.
And you effectively pass
it a callback function.
And this will ensure that your
callback function will get
pushed into the proper queues.
And it will be called in the
main thread the next time a
frame process happens.
Now what's nice about this is
that this allows you, on the
calling thread, to then set a
conditional data variable and
sit around and wait.
So with this function here, you
actually issue a function
command, wait until it has been
called and executed on
the main thread and control
has been returned.
And you can see on the bottom
here, this is the return from
main thread function.
Effectively what this does is,
first off, asserts that you're
on the main thread, because
you want to make sure your
code's clean.
You want to make sure you're
doing the right thing.
And then it will actually get
the information that has been
passed to it as a callback
parameter, set some result,
and then signal the conditional
signal.
That signal right there, that
event, that p thread
conditional, will allow the
worker thread, the logic
thread, that actually issued the
command to then wake up,
continue doing what it was
doing, and move on.
This is fantastic.
With these two little functions
right here, you can
implement a structure around it
that allow you to overload
f read and f write and those
other functions to be blocking
functions from the
logic thread.
So this is effectively
what happens.
You end up in a situation where
you start calling data.
It blocks.
Comes back.
Calls data, blocks,
comes back.
And this is fine for a lot of
functions that you expect to
work this way.
Your architecture will
transition over seamlessly.
And you won't have to
worry about it.
The problem turns into function
APIs that don't
benefit from working
in this fashion.
For example, rendering.
Rendering works very
differently.
Rendering expects that I
shouldn't have to block for
lots and lots of frames to
submit each instance.
In that situation, what you want
to do is for these types
of calls that are best for
fire and forget, that you
don't actually wait
for a response.
These things don't need
any information back
from the main thread.
As such, you should just fire
them off very quickly and
allow the logic thread
to move on.
So you can see here you get
three fires really quick.
And then the Pepper thread
spends its time doing the
proper resource handling to the
underlying architecture
without you having to block.
Now for rendering, there's
actually a different process
involved here that you can
actually think about in a
different way.
A very modern graphics engine
mechanic is actually the
concept of buffering up all of
your draw commands, submitting
them off to the Pepper thread at
a various form, so that it
kind of gets the entire frame.
And then it starts queuing
through it properly.
So what happens is your logic
thread will go and do the
rendering, actually
create the calls.
But instead of actually doing
the rendering and calling the
APIs, what happens is you
overload the API to create a
small, little representation,
like a quad word or some form
of it that gets pushed
into an FIFO.
And that FIFO is then consumed
by the Pepper thread, and
issued off to the appropriate
engines below that.
Now this is important, that what
you're effectively doing
here is you're creating a
waterfall processing method,
or a producer consumer FIFO
between your logic thread and
your Pepper thread, where the
logic thread will do logic
frame n, kick off the rendering
results for that.
And render thread will then do
render frame n while the logic
thread moves on to
the next frame.
This, again, is a very
common paradigm for
next generation consoles--
Xbox 360, PS3.
This is what you're doing
in a lot of your
systems right here.
Traditionally they call the
Pepper thread the render
thread at that point.
And there's some variation
of what data is
pushed between the two.
In this particular method, you
want no logic occurring on the
Pepper thread other than just
rendering your data.
So that's the ecosystem
that you're in.
That's sort of what you're
dealing with.
Basically, what you need to do
is spin off a logic threat and
then modify your code such that
you handle two different
types of calls.
You've got the calls that
require feedback from the
Pepper thread.
And then those you need to
block and wait for that
information to return.
And then you've got the
fire and forget calls.
And those are the calls that
you just either issue
immediately and then
keep moving on.
Or you bundle up into some
sort of frame or boundary
mechanic and submit in one
batch, and then let the Pepper
thread do its thing while you're
logic thread moves on.
So once you understand the
environment that you're in,
because of the Pepper API
restrictions, which are
temporary, by the way, now you
can actually start porting the
rest of your code.
And this involves understanding
at a number of levels.
So let's dive in.
The first is FileIO.
So if you've never developed a
web game, let me clue you in
on some specific information.
You're going to put your HTML
datas and your NEXE datas and
your NMF datas on some
server somewhere.
And when the user loads your
page that embeds this module,
it's going to be received by the
client and auto-cached by
Chrome on your behalf.
This is just going to happen
automatically.
And it will grab the HTML data,
the NEXE data, and the
NMF data and cache it for
you because it's defined
in the embed tag.
And this is great.
This means that Chrome
is handling your
caching on your behalf.
You don't have to do
anything else.
You just sit back, hands
behind your head,
allow it all to happen.
It's good to go.
The problem is that
there's other data
that your game needs.
There are zip files, for
instance, ZIP0 and ZIP1.
These will not be pulled down
automatically for you when the
user loads your page.
Instead, for these, you have to
use a GetURL API inside of
Pepper or an XHR request
inside of JavaScript.
And that will pull down
these binary assets.
Now the cool thing is that
with this call, with the
GetURL call, it will also
cache itself in
Chrome on your behalf.
So you can actually fetch
these zip files.
Chrome will cache it.
And then the next time the
user asks for it, it will
already be in the cache.
And they can get it from there,
as opposed to going
back to the server, which
is a longer round trip.
One of the interesting things
about this, though, is that
when your data is in the cache,
it can also be evicted
from the cache at
any single time.
The user can go and load a
website which uses more data.
Or they can clear the
cache themselves.
But basically, they can purge
all of this asset storing that
you're doing on their behalf, so
that the experience in your
game is not as optimal
as it should be.
And this is a bad thing.
To answer this, there's actually
a cool little API
inside of Pepper called
the File Store API.
The File Store API will allow
you to grab data inside of the
client's memory and store it
to a persistent sandboxed
obfuscated file store.
Now, this data will exist on
disk until one of two things
happens or both will happen.
The user navigates to this
sandbox system somehow through
their API and their operating
system and
manually deletes the data.
Or your program deletes
the data.
So effectively this allows you
to take control over the
caching mechanisms that
are used during
this transfer process.
So definitely make sure
you're using that.
You can click the link at
the bottom here for more
information.
That actually directs
to gonacl.com.
We have a specific article
on how to do all this.
FileIO and shutdown.
Console developers in here, you
will help me lament over
the process of trying to write
to a memory stick that has
been pushed into a console.
And as you're writing, the
user rips the stick out
because they think it's done.
And now, all of a sudden,
you have--
effectively the world
explodes.
The data written to
disk is corrupted.
The information being
transferred is corrupted.
And the user is mad at you
because you didn't know they
were going to rip
the stick out.
Who knows?
Well, anyhow, in a web page
you have the same problem.
When you're trying to write data
to your persistent file
store, the user can tab away.
They can close the data.
A crash can occur.
Something can happen
that effectively
does the same process.
It effectively deteriorates
the data.
Stops the write.
Causes problems of all sorts.
So if you've actually opened
this file and tried to write
to it, when you try to load it
the next time around, the
information is going
to be corrupt.
Basically, you're going
to lose it.
The better methodology here is
for any writes to file, what
you actually want to do is write
to a separate file or a
duplicate file and communicate
all of your data there.
And then once all of your
writing has been finalized, at
the end of your process, you
actually then move, rename,
some process, over to the
intended position.
And this means-- what occurs
here is that if the chance
that the user corrupts the data
during the write to the
persistent file store, that it
doesn't actually corrupt the
original data on disks.
So when the user loads the game
next time, all they've
lost is the delta between the
last time they've saved, as
opposed to your entire saved
file, which is a good thing.
Now for those of you who are
doing FileIO, there is a
really cool mode that's recent,
that's actually a
dangerous FileIO.
And there's some terminology
about why you want to call it
dangerous or not.
But this is really helpful
to those of you who are
developers.
So in developer mode, you can
actually write directly to
disk outside of the obfuscated
sandbox.
This is really helpful.
Effectively, when you launch
Chrome, you can send an
environment variable, NaCl
Dangerous Enable File Access.
And then you run Chrome
with no sandbox.
This effectively turns off some
of the security handles
that you have available
to you.
And then in the code, in your
C code, you actually do a
direct f open and start
writing to it.
And what this will do is
actually create a file in the
application location
of where NaCl is.
So for instance, path to Chrome
slash build number.
That's where NaCl.exe exists.
So with this set up here,
this actually creates a
tracelog.txt in my application
folder for Chrome 19, which is
currently in Canary.
This is amazing.
So for those of you developers
who are trying to do inline
profiling or trying to dump
crash disks or crash logs to
disk in these sorts of fashions,
having to wait for
the asynchronous file system
is just not doable.
Instead, you actually want
to control writing
directly to a disk.
And this gives you
that ability.
This is really important.
It allows you to move
forward with getting
all this stuff done.
And you can click that
link there for more.
It's got more information on
it and how you use it.
Rendering.
So first off, Native Client
uses OpenGL ES 2.0 as a
rendering API.
So this is the same API that's
used on mobile devices today.
Porting your game to use
this is step one.
So if you're using DirectX, you
need to port your stuff
over to OpenGL first, because
that will be an easy
transition for you.
And then from OpenGL, you need
to move to OpenGL ES 2.0.
You can do this using a project
called ANGLE on Windows.
If you click that link,
there's a source code
repository there where
the entire
source code is available.
Effectively, ANGLE is a dll
suite that provides OpenGL ES
2.0 headers that you can then
target that will translate to
DirectX calls internally.
So you can effectively test how
your code is working and
do this all on Windows.
To note, there's no OpenGL ES
2.0 runtime on Windows.
It doesn't exist. So if you're
going to try to test this on
Windows, you're going to
need to use ANGLE.
Specifically, you need
to know that OpenGL
ES 2.0 is not OpenGL.
There's a stricter set
of compiler rules.
And this is because we need to
make sure that security is
step one for the end user.
The developer, your experience
that you're trying to
communicate, that's all
fine and dandy.
Keeping the user safe is more
important than all of that.
And not all the extensions
are available.
So, for instance, if you're
expecting instancing or access
to a specific tessellation
shader, they're just not going
to be there.
This is an API.
This is handled by the Khronos
group and then rolling the
feature sets out is sort of
tiered because we have to go
through those bodies.
But make sure that you
understand that OpenGL ES 2.0
and OpenGL are not
the same thing.
Specifically, for API nuances.
For instance, in OpenGL you
can create a compressed
texture and not pass any
information into it.
So you can just say, hey, create
this blank texture, and
I'll fill it in later.
OpenGL ES 2.0, actually, this
is considered an error.
If you try to do this, it
will actually crash.
Now the problem is this is
not well documented.
And if you go to the Native
Client forums, you'll actually
see about 10 or 11 people,
myself included, complaining
about this problem and asking
for a solution.
The reality is that this is an
OpenGL E 2.0 spec that is not
compatible with OpenGL.
Make sure you test all of
this stuff properly.
And definitely make sure you're
checking the API before
you start blaming Native Client,
because a lot of the
times the problem is there.
So the next thing you need to be
aware of when you're doing
rendering is that
you're actually
rendering from a sandbox.
Now because of security issues,
we don't actually
allow your code to directly
go to the driver.
When you do a set command or a
draw command or anything, we
don't actually go right
to the API.
Instead, what occurs
is we have a
separate render process.
The render process is
responsible for handling all
the interaction with the API.
Nothing else goes through
this render
process except API calls.
Now to get from the Pepper
thread to the render process,
though, we actually create
an RPC buffer.
Now what happens is the Pepper
thread will push commands into
the RPC buffer.
And then that buffer will be
flushed at some time later to
the render process.
This basically creates about a
frame of latency between a
producer-consumer FIFO that
you need to be aware of.
What happens with this
producer-consumer FIFO,
though, is that your RPC
buffer, sooner or
later, will get full.
So what happens is you
draw an object.
You update your vertex buffer.
You go to draw an object again,
and the buffer's full.
So then it stalls.
What happens here is you hit
something called a flush sink
or sink flush, depending on
which documentation you get.
What happens here is that the
process, even though you're
not done with your frame,
will actually halt.
And it will say, hey,
we're done here.
I'm full.
And it will actually
issue a flush sink.
Now, what will happen here is
that it blocks the processing
and calling thread until all
of the data inside that RPC
buffer has been consumed
by the render process.
What this means to you is
you'll start seeing
30-millisecond spikes randomly
in your game,
hitches in weird places.
When you start debugging and
profiling down into it, you'll
see random calls all of a sudden
taking 30 milliseconds.
And to you this is going
to be maddening.
You're going try to figure out
why this one draw object is
taking 30 milliseconds.
Is it the pixel shader?
Is it the number of vertices?
Yada, yada.
You'll start moving the thing
around and noticing that it
never happens on the same draw
call, that it happens sort of
as a temporal problem.
And what the real problem is
is that the RPC buffer is
getting full.
So make sure you note
that ahead of time.
Now how you combat this is
kind of interesting.
First off, swap buffers actually
kicks off a GL finish
call on your behalf.
GL finish will actually
force a flush to
occur of the RPC buffer.
So you fill in a frame.
You hit swap buffers.
And then you start filling
in the next frame.
And that swap buffers will push
everything off to the
render process on your behalf.
The goal here is to implement
these flushes in strategic
locations inside of your render
loop, so that you never
hit a sink flush.
So effectively what you're doing
is continuously pushing
the data and forcing that RPC
buffer to flush, so that you
never hit these 30-millisecond
waits.
So you need to do is once
you draw some stuff,
you insert a flush.
You draw some more stuff, and
you insert another flush.
Now the key here is that
figuring out where to insert
these GL flush calls.
That's the trick.
To do that what you have to do
is you have to go back and
analyze your frame.
You got to take a look at where
the heavy spots are,
where you're hitting your flush
sinks, and then figure
out, hey, I need to insert a GL
flush manually before I hit
that point to save me
30 milliseconds.
Basically, what you're trying to
do is keep that RPC buffer
continuously moving to keep
your frames from getting
stalled out.
So once you understand how all
this works and how you're
rendering, how the rendering
occurs, and how the rendering
happens between the Chrome and
Native Client module in the
rendering process, you need to
take a step back and take a
view of the bigger picture,
which is 3D and the web.
3D API's, as well documented,
can be malicious on the web.
As much as we would like
to admit it, the web is
homogeneous.
But GPUs and hardware are not.
You've got a different
machine.
Heck, my coffee cup has a
different GPU processing in it
than any of you, which I think
this is a 9,800, but we'll get
back to that later.
So the problem here is that
because of the fact that some
of these drivers can be
malicious, WebGL actually has
a list of blacklisted
3D drivers.
Most of the time if a driver
has a problem, we can say,
hey, here's the problem.
Submit it to the vendor.
The vendor can fix it and
push out a patch to it.
In the situations where this
doesn't occur, we effectively
have to say we have to blacklist
the driver because
this is a malicious piece of
software that can cause
problems on the end user's
machine and expose them to
potential security risks.
And because of that, the user
can hit a web page, and we can
say, hey, you're not allowed
to run WebGL.
You're not allowed
to run OpenGL
inside of Native Client.
And to detect this, effectively
what happens is
you fail to create a context.
That's the basic thing.
The first thing you do in any
OpenGL-style system is you
create a GL context.
When that fails, it means
one of two things.
Either the user doesn't have the
proper hardware to run any
WebGL or OpenGL.
Or the user has a set of
blacklisted drivers.
Your job is to detect this
and respond very early.
Because I'll tell you, nothing
is more annoying than a user
spending an hour and a half
trying to get your game to run
and updating drivers and
updating Chrome and doing this
and that to finally get down to
and realize the problem is
they needed to go update a patch
or that they just can't
do it in general.
Make sure you update this early
and tell the users, so
you can save them
all that time.
To do this is is actually
really simple.
Here's a little snippet of
code that you can use in
JavaScript.
So this is way before Native
Client even loads.
So the user loads your page.
You're going to execute this
snippet of JavaScript to
determine whether or not the
user is blacklisted first. OK.
Basically what you do is you try
to create a WebGL context.
If that WebGL context fails,
you can alert the user
immediately, immediately that
they either have blacklisted
hardware, or they don't
have hardware
sufficient to run this.
If it passes, then you know the
user has a system that can
run your game, your 3D game.
And you can also do some
other cool stuff here.
Since you have the context,
you can go ahead and test
additional extensions.
Like does the user have
occlusion calling?
Or does the user have
the ability to run
4096 by 4096 textures?
You can do all this in
JavaScript before you start
loading all of your NEXEs and
start transferring your binary
data from the web.
This is really cool to do.
The link at the bottom here,
actually, links to a specific
example of how to do all this.
As well as you should take a
look at the load progress
example in the SDK.
It has this as well as a fleet
of other tasks that you should
be doing, as well as detecting
download process and
displaying that to your users.
So make sure that that's part
of your best practices.
Working in a browser.
So you understand the
environment you're in.
You understand the hitches and
the hurdles that you're going
to have to jump for FileIO and
rendering and all the problems
associated with that.
So now let's talk about working
inside of a browser.
So this has less to do with your
technology and your code
and more to do with
the ecosystem that
you're living in.
So first off is NaCl
white listing.
Native Client is not enabled
inside of Chrome until an
action occurs.
This is for a number
of reasons,
predominately security.
If there's an issue in Native
Client that we're not aware
of, we don't want malicious code
just sitting around on
the internet.
We want some way to make sure
that random users are not at
the mercy of a problem
that we find.
So Native Client is not enabled
until one of two things.
First off, for developers, you
can turn on Native Client by a
flag in the about flags page.
So this will allow you, as a
developer, to get access to
any Native Client content
that exists on the web.
For users, though, you don't
want them setting a flag.
Users have to go through
a different path.
They actually install the game
from the Chrome web store.
And what happens here is that
the Chrome web store will
actually list the origin that
you've specified for your NaCl
module, so basically where
it's resting on a server.
So I've got a website,
mainroach.blogspot.com.
And I host my Native
Client app there.
When I create my Chrome Web
Store instance, I say that my
Native Client application
will be hosted for
mainroach.blogspot.com.
When you install that, as
a user, that origin,
mainroach.blogspot.com will
get listed inside of your
preferences as a white
listed location.
Hey, it's OK to serve
Native Client
content from this location.
And note that the NMF and
the NEXEs must be
loaded from that location.
You can put zip data in
different places and aug files
and JavaScript all on
a content network,
wherever you want them.
But the NEXEs and the NMFs
must exist from that
white-listed origin.
So once you've done that,
you have a pretty
easy way to test this.
So you can actually determine
beforehand whether or not the
user actually has Native
Client enabled or
available to install.
So first off, you need to detect
whether or not the user
is running Chrome.
As of today, much to my dismay,
Chrome is the only one
that uses and installs
Native Client.
So first off, to determine if a
user can run Native Client,
you need to detect if they're
using Chrome.
Secondly the Chrome web store
has a really cool API called
window.chrome.app.isinstalled.
And you can define in this
whether or not the application
defined on this page has
been installed from
the Chrome web store.
Now because an end user has
to install a Native Client
application from the Chrome web
store, this is effectively
your test to determine if
the user can run it.
So if some user randomly browses
to your web page that
doesn't have Native Client
installed or hasn't installed
it from the web store, you can
detect it here and direct them
to install it.
You can also use something
called Inline Install, which
is a great little nifty feature
from the Chrome web
store, too.
But the important thing here
is that you need to detect
this and tell the user because,
otherwise, they're
going to browse to
your website.
And then they'll get a plug-in
request. And they're going to
be like, hey, what's this?
This is crummy.
I'm going to give you zero star
reviews, and send you
pictures that you don't
want to see.
Definitely click the link at
the bottom of this slide.
And also check out the load
progress example in the SDK
for more on that.
Now for developers, it's worth
pointing out that the Chrome
caching mechanism is
both aggressive,
amazing, and magical.
How well it caches data and
how aggressive it is at
keeping it around to make sure
that you're always hitting the
cache as opposed to going
to the web is
really a thing of beauty.
The problem is for those of us
game developers who do test,
launch, and iterate patterns,
this is a problem.
Because as I change some code,
deploy it to Chrome, and then
iterate on that content, I
want the latest version.
I don't want the
cached version.
To get around this, because
Chrome will bite you in this
matter, you can actually go
to the developer tools and
actually turn off caching.
You can disable caching, so that
Chrome will always try to
fetch the most recent version
and won't ever try to grab the
data from the cache.
Now, it's worth pointing out
that you probably don't want
to do this on the version of
Chrome that you're running
every day because otherwise your
browser will just slow
down in general.
But make sure that in your
developer version of Chrome
that you're doing
it like this.
Now also while you're developing
in Chrome, there's
a whole fleet of tools that
will help you in your
development.
And these are called the
Chrome developer tools.
You can click the link to the
more expansive declaration.
But effectively, you can click
on the wrench, go down to
tools, and go down to
developer tools.
And this will launch a small
little bar at the bottom of
your window that has a number
of options here--
elements, resources, network
views, et cetera.
One of the cool things about
this is that it actually
provides a networking view.
The networking view actually
lists all of the asset
requests that your module has
made through Chrome over the
lifetime of its application.
So you can actually see, hey,
am I loading my zip file.
Am I loading my audio data?
How long does it take
to fetch that?
Can I change anything
to make that faster?
Can I bundle things up
to make that easier?
These are sort of quintessential
tools that you
need to be using, if you're
starting to develop inside of
Chrome, especially the console
tab, which will tell you a lot
of errors the Native Client
spits out that you may not be
able to catch in
other fashions.
Another amazing tool
is About Tracing.
So if you open up Chrome, and
you create a new tab, and you
type in the address bar About
Tracing, it will take you to
this great API here, which
effectively is an inline
profiler view of Chrome.
So it actually shows you what
thread is running and what
blocks of time is
running there.
And it allows you to drill down
to actually get the name
of the function being called.
The best part about this is you
can actually issue data
into About Tracing from
JavaScript or, subsequently,
Native Client.
And the even cooler thing about
this is see that little
Load button over there?
You can write out an
inline profile.
So for those of you who have
inline profilers that already
exist in your game, you can
modify it to output adjacent
file that matches what this tool
uses, and use Chrome to
do all of the profiling
in your game.
It's an entire tool that allows
you to get all this
progress and availability
to you free of charge.
You don't have to
write the UI.
You don't have to do that.
We got a guy dedicated
to writing this.
Use this tool.
It's amazing to see.
Google Stack.
So now we've talked about what
the ecosystem is and all this
other stuff.
So let's talk about what
Google can do to
help you with this.
So you've got your game.
You can serve your content, your
database information, off
of Google App Engine.
So this is basically your
database handling and your
asset distribution.
We have the Chrome web store
that we've already talked
about and touched on,
which handles
distribution and discovery.
You also need to install your
Native Client apps from there
to white list them.
We've got Google Wallet, which
helps you monetize through
in-app payments and everything
else along those lines.
Once you've got all that, you're
eventually going to
want some sort of social graph,
so that people can
detect and move between
friends and submit
information.
We've got Google+ And then,
finally, we've got Google
Analytics, which is an amazingly
powerful tool that
allows you to detect what your
users are doing, how they're
doing it, and kick off
events to match that.
Now definitely check out my
other talk today on best
practices in developing a web
application to do a deep dive
on the way to properly use
these for your web game.
Check it out, and
leave comments.
I highly appreciate it.
That's all for me.
Make sure you check out
gonacl.com for the best
information available.
And then you can find me on all
of these different places,
especially
mainroach.blogspot.com.
So, hey, thank you
for your time.
Appreciate your comments.
Drop me a line.
I'd love to hear from you.
Thank you.